Republicans are saying that they are now
worried that if marijuana is legalized
police dogs will be treated like dogs
and put out of work the police dogs will
lose their jobs to me this has always
been one of the silliest reasons to
defend the status quo and the
prototypical example is I don't know
about cars because if cars become the
norm it will put the horse buggy drivers
out of a job and of course imagine today
in 2023 still having no cars and horses
and Buggies foregoing motor vehicle
technology because we've got to keep the
horse buggy drivers employed it seems
very silly there's a broader issue here
called technological unemployment
historically new technologies typically
create more jobs than they destroy that
may change with AI Etc but this isn't
even a question of technological
unemployment